สวัสดีค่ะครูนิกสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับค่ะสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนอ่ะเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่ก่อนนะคะ
ครูริงวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวัน
อังคารวันนี้วัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 23 ครับ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
สิงหาคมปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ครับค่ะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
ครับเมืองที่ครูนิกอยู่อยู่เวลา
นาที
834 น 88:30 นหน่อยๆไม่มีใครพูดเนาะ
88:30 นหน่อยๆของครูนิกถ้าจะบอกก็บอกว่า
อ๋อ 800 นไม่ใช่ก็ไม่พูด 88:30 นใช่ 8 น
835 นคุณนิจะชอบพูดเลขกลมๆ 5 อะไรแบบ
เนี้ยอือือไม่แบบ 1  2  3  4 ใช่มั้คุคิด
ว่ามันมันละเอียดเกินไปนแค่ 1 นาทีเองเออ
1 นาทีแล้วเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่เวลากี่
โมงครับเมืองที่ครูหญิงอยู่ตอนนี้เร็ว
กว่าครูนิก 1 ชมงนะคะก็ 9 น 34 นนะคะ 9:30
นแล้วอืโอเคอืใช่ครูนิกสบายดีนะคะสบายดี
ครับสบายดีเพิ่งกินกาแฟหมดเพิ่งดื่มกาแฟ
หมดเพิ่งดื่มกาแฟหมดนะใช่ก็วันนี้เนี่ยนะ
คะครูหญิงจะมีเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรมี
ปริศนาปริศนาโอเคครับูมีปริศนามาเล่นกับ
ครูนิกคือมันก็จะเป็นเหมือนคำถามนั่นแหละ
ค่ะครับแต่ว่าครูหญิงก็จะมีเหมือนคำให้
ก่อนอืถามยาวๆเสร็จแล้วครูนิดฟังแล้วแล้ว
เนี่ยคิดว่าสิ่งที่ครูหญิงพูดเนี่ยมันคือ
อะไรโอเคอ่ะได้ได้ครับลองดูลองดูว่าจะคิด
ออกมย
ลองครับจริงๆเนี่ยมันยากมากนะพวกปริศนา
แบบเนี้ยมันต้องแบบคนที่ชอบเล่นจริงๆคือ
คุณนิกอ่ะเคยเล่นไอ้เกมปริศนาแบบนี้เนี่ย
คุณนิก็ไม่เคยตอบถูกเลยนะ
ใช่คือใช่แต่ของครูหญิงเนี่ยนะคะมันจะ
เป็นแบบที่เลือกมาเนาะมันจะเป็นปริศนา
สำหรับเด็กหน่อยมันจะไม่ยากมากสำหรับเรา
แต่ด้วยความที่มันไม่ได้เป็นภาษาไทยอ่า
อลองดูลองดูลองดูนะครูนิกไม่เป็นไรค่ะครู
นิกทำได้แน่นอนครูหญิงมั่นใจนะคะเออโอเค
อ่ะปริศนาที่ 1 นะคะ
อะไรที่ขึ้นได้ลงได้
แต่ขยับไม่
ได้ขึ้นได้ขึ้นได้ลงได้แต่ขยับไม่ได้ไม่
ได้
อะไรอ่าใบ้ให้นิดหน่อยแล้วกันเ้ายังยัง
ไม่ต้องเนาเคุณนี้เตอบได้คุณนิกกำลังคิด
ว่าคิดว่าอะไรคะ
เอ่อคุณนิคิดว่า
ใช่อุณหภูมิหรือเปล่า
อ่าก็คือแบบว่าเซลเซียสฟาเรนไฮต์เซีย
ฟาเรนไฮเพราะว่ามันก็จะเราเราก็จะพูดว่า
อ๋ออุณหภูมิขึ้นณหภูมิลง
ออไม่รู้ว่าใช่มั้ยเพราะคิดว่ามันไม่ขยับ
แบบอย่างเงี้ยมันขึ้นกับลงมันเป็นมันเป็น
ของมันเป็นของมั้ยอ่ะมันก็ไม่รู้ว่ามัน
เรียกว่าของหรือเปล่าอ่ะค่ะครูนิกแต่ว่า
มันเป็นอะไรที่เรามองเห็นได้แล้ว
ก็ที่
บ้านบางบ้านอาจจะมีอ่าแต่ว่าถ้า
เป็นตึกใช่มยตึกมี 1 ชั้น 2 ชั้น 3 ชั้น
อย่างเงี้ยมีแน่นอน
อ๋อลิฟหรือเปล่าคล้ายๆคล้ายคล้าด้วยลิฟ
มันขยับได้ไงครูนิกมันขยับขึ้นขยับลงได้
ก็ลิฟขยับขึ้นขยับ
ลงเนี่ยมันขยับไม่ได้เลยมันอยู่เฉยๆแต่
มันขึ้นได้ลง
ได้
เอ๊คือถ้าบ้านครูนิกมีแค่ 1 ชั้นน่าจะไม่
มีแต่ถ้าบ้านครูนิกมี 2 ชั้นมีแน่นอนอ
บันไดใช่
มยใช่
ค่ะยากนะูนี้กลับบ้าน
ละโอเคสวัสดีครับนัก
เรียน
คุนิกต้องอยู่เล่นก่อนไเอ้าว้ายเฉลยไป
แล้วอ้าๆคุณนิกไม่เห็นเลยเมื่อกี้อะไรนะ
โอเคโอเคอ่ะนี่ใช่มั้ยคะบันไดเนี่ยเรา
เดินขึ้นบันไดได้อืเราเดินลงบันไดได้แต่
บันไดเนี่ยมันขยับไม่ได้อ๋อโอเคอ๋อแต่
ลิฟตเนี่ยมัน
ขยับใช่ลิฟต์เนี่ยมันขึ้นได้ลงได้แต่มัน
ขยับขึ้นขยับลงไงออโอเคโอเคได้ค่ะเก่งมาก
คุณอ่ะข้อที่ 2 นะคะข้อที่ 2 ก็คือ
อ่าอะไรที่มันจะเป็นสีขาวอืนะสีขาวเวลา
ที่
สกปรกแล้วก็จะเป็นสีดำเนาะสีดำเหมือนผม
ของเราเนี่ยนะคะสีดำเวลาที่มัน
สะอาดคือเราต้องคิดว่าถ้าสีขาวคือสะอาดนะ
ปกติสีขาวเนี่ยสะอาดอืสีดำสีดำเนี่ยสกปรก
อันนี้คือ
ปกติอืแต่ปริศนาอันนี้นะคะเวลาที่มัน
สกปรกคือมันตรงข้ามกันเนาะสกปรกเป็นสีขาว
แต่ถ้าสะอาดจะเป็นสีดำอะไรอ่ะใบให้ด้วยดี
กว่าอันนี้เนี่ยใช้ที่โรง
เรียนโรงเรียนเนี่ยน่าจะคุณเปิด Google
เหรอคะไม่คนนี้กำลังคิดอยู่ว่าเอ๊ะคือ
อะไรนักเรียนบอกคู่นี้ันหน้าไปไหนหยิบ
โทรศัพท์ขึ้นมาเปิด Google หรือเปล่า
โทรศัพท์อยู่
นี่นี้กำลังคิดว่าอะไรวะอ
ของชิ้นนี้เนี่ยส่วนใหญ่เลยนะเราจะเห็น
ที่โรงเรียนแต่อาจจะเป็นแบบโรงเรียนโรง
เรียนปัจจุบันนี้อาจจะไม่มีแล้วหรือเปล่า
ไม่รู้นะ
คะ
อะไรอะไรนะที่มันจะเป็นถ้ามันสกปรกจะเป็น
สีขาวแต่ถ้ามันสะอาดมันจะมีมันจะเป็นสี
ดำอื
อืคู่นี้
คิดคิดไม่ออกขาวแต่
สกปรกคือคุณนิกอ่ะคุณนิกำลังคิดว่ามันน่า
จะเป็นมันน่าจะ
เป็นคืออันนี้เป็นของใช้นะเออเป็นของคือ
คุณนี้กำลังคิดว่ามันน่าจะเป็นช็อแต่ว่า
ช็อกเนี่ยส่วนใหญ่เนี่ยมันสีขาว
แต่มันไปเขียนที่ไหนมันก็มันก็สกปรกแต่
ถ้าไม่เขียนมันก็ไม่ใช่สีดำแต่ว่ามัน
เขียนที่ไหนล่ะคุณนิดใกล้มากใกล้มากช็อ
เนี่ยใช่ค่ะมันคือคือช็อกเนี่ยมันทำให้
สกปรกนั่นแหละแต่ช็อกมันทำอะไรให้
สกปรกมัน
ก็มันเขียนบนพื้นบนกำแพงไงแต่พอมันลบแล้ว
มันก็ไม่ใช่สีดำนะก็ไม่ๆแต่ช็อเราจะเขียน
ที่
ไหนเขียนที่ไหนปกติแล้วอ่ะเราจะเห็นช็อ
เขียนหรือว่าโรงเรียนครูนิกไม่มีโรงเรียน
ูนเป็นอ้อเขียนบนหมายถึงกระดานดำใช่มยใช่
ค่ะครูนิกโอ้เก่งมากนะเออเอแบบนี่ๆๆอ่ะ
เดี๋ยวโอโอเคเก่งมากค่ะแบบุหญิงแบบคุนี้
ใกล้แล้วได้แล้วแต่จอ่ะกระดานดำเนี่ยครุณ
นิกเมื่อก่อนครุณนิกก็ไม่เข้าใจนะว่าทำไม
เรียกกระดานดำเพราะคุณนิเห็นน่ะมันสี
เขียวอือ
ๆใช่ค่ะโรงเรียนไทยเนี่ยมันสีเขียวใช่
เมื่อก่อนเนี่ยไอ้ที่เป็นที่เขาเขียนกัน
น่ะมันอาจจะเป็นสีดำมาก่อนแล้วอือพอรุ่น
เราเนี่ยก็เลยเป็นสีเขียวเหมือนมัน
เปลี่ยนอืใช่ค่ะครุณนี้ก็ถูกใช่มั้ย
กระดานดำอันนี้คือเราเรียกกระดานดำนะคะ
หรือว่าแต่ถ้าปัจจุบันนี้มันไม่ได้เป็น
กระดานดำเนาะมันอาจจะเป็นไวท์บอร์ดนะคะ
แต่สมัยก่อนเนี่ยกระดานดำเนี่ยมันคือสีดำ
ถ้ามันเป็นสีดำแบบนี้ก็คือมันสะอาดใช่
มั้ยมันยังไม่ได้ผ่านการเขียนแต่ถ้าเมื่อ
ไหร่มันมีช็อสีสีขาวมาเขียนก็คือสีขาวมัน
ก็สกปรกนะคะปริศนาอันนี้เนี่ยเขาก็พูดถึง
กระดานดับอันนี้ครูนิกเก่งมากครุณนิกปวด
หัวเลยนะเมื่อ
กี้นักเรียนบอกโอ้ปวดหัวเหมือนกันนะคะอ่ะ
อันนี้อ่ะข้อต่อไปแล้วกันครับ
เอ่ออะไร
ที่มันจะมี
มีมันจะมีค่าน้อยลงครับถ้ามันกลับหัวอ่ะ
สมมุติอันนี้เป็นขวดใช่มั้ยคะขวดน้ำเนี่ย
มันตั้งอยู่แบบนี้ใช่มั้ยแบบนี้คือกลับ
หัวนะกลับหัวนะคะอะไรที่มันจะแบบน้อยลง
ถ้ามันกลับหัวคือขวดน้ำเนี่ยกลับหัวมันก็
เท่าเดิมอือ่าแต่อะไรที่มันกลับหัวแล้ว
มันจะน้อย
ลงอันนี้เป็นไม่ใช่ของ
เอ้าไม่ใช่ของด้วยไม่ใช่ของอันนี้โอ้พูด
พูดถ้าคุหญิงใบ้คุณนี้ก็จะรู้เลยนะคะมัน
เป็น
จำนวเรียกจำนวน
เหรอถ้ากลับหัวแล้วมันจะน้อยลงหรอใช่มัน
จะมีค่าน้อย
ลง
แต่มันไม่ใช่ของด้วยมันไม่ใช่ของค่ะมันจะ
มีค่าน้อย
ลงค่าก็คือเป็นราคาเนาะเหมือนราคาอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยเป็นค่ามันจะมีค่าน้อยลงถ้ามัน
กลับ
หัวมันเป็นจำนวนค่ะครูนิก
จำนวนลองคิดดูว่ามีอะไรที่แบบมันตั้งอยู่
อย่างงี้แต่เมื่อไหร่ที่มันกลับหัวปุ๊บ
มันเปลี่ยนน่ะแล้วมันก็น้อยลง
โอ้โหอะไร
อ่ะ
อืถ้าพูดอันนี้ครูนิจะรู้เลย
มยลองคิดดูแล้วกันว่าเวลาที่เราทำ
อันเนี้ยเราอาจจะต้องแบบขีดเอาไว้ให้รู้
ว่ามันคืออันนี้นะเพราะว่าถ้าเราเห็นเป็น
สี่เหลี่ยมแล้วเราแบบจับมาเราอาจจะไม่รู้
ว่ามันคือเลขอัโอ๊ยพูดไป
แล้วมันคือจำนวนอะไร
ออหมาย
ถึงตัวเลขหรอช่จำนวนใช่ค่ะ
อาฮะ
ถ้าหยถึงเลข 9 ใช่
มั้ยใช่ค่ะเพราะถ้าเลข 9 กลับหัวจะเป็น
เลข 6 ใช่ค่ะอ่ะเดี๋ยวให้นักเรียนโอเค
เข้าใจแล้วครับเข้าใจใช่มยอ่าเลข 9 ใช่มย
อันนี้คือเลข 9 เพราะเลข 9 มันกลับหัว
ครับมันก็จะเป็นเลข 6 ใช่มนักเรียนลองมอง
ี้ก็ได้มันจะเป็นเลข 6  9 เนี่ย
อ่ามากกว่า 6 ใช่มยครับครับมากกว่า 6 ใช่
มั้ยพอมันกลับหัวปุ๊บมันก็เลยมีค่าน้อยลง
นะคะก็คือเลข 9
โอโห
เ้อเก่งมากนะแบบถ้าใบ้ให้ครูหญิงเนี่ยครู
หญิงคิดแบบสมองอะไสมองคุณนิกตอนนี้
เหนื่อยแล้วอ่ะอีกอันนึงนะคะอันนี้เนี่ย
อันเนี้ยพอครูหญิงดูเฉลยแล้วครูหญิงก็ออ
คือเราไม่รู้ว่าเรารู้หรือเปล่านะแต่ว่า
ลองเล่นสนุกๆแล้วกันได้ครับได้อะไรที่มีต
ตามีตานะแต่ตาเนี่ยมองไม่
เห็นคือเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรอ่ะอะไรที่มีตา
ใช่แต่ตาที่มีเนี่ยมันมองมันดูไม่ได้โอเค
ตามันดูไม่ได้มองไม่เห็นเหมือนครูนิกครู
หญิงแล้วก็นักเรียนเนี่ยมีตาใช่มั้คะแต่
ตาเราเนี่ยมองเห็นอือืแต่อะไรที่มีตาแต่
มองไม่เห็น
อือันนี้ไม่ใช่ของไม่ใช่คนไม่ใช่
สัตว์เป็นธรรมชาติแบบต้นไม้ภูเขาทะเลอะไร
อย่างเงี้ยมันเป็นธรรมชาติเกิดขึ้น
เองอืฝนฟ้าอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
ธรรมชาติธรรมชาติเหรอเอออันนี้ครูหญิงไม่
เคยรู้เหมือนกันกันน่ะค่ะเพราะว่า 1
ประเทศไทยก็ไม่มีประเทศไทยไม่มีสิ่งนี้
แต่อเมริกาเนี่ยมี
อืถ้าต้องคิดถึงอันเนี้ยเราจะคิดถึง
อเมริกาเลยอ่ะอเมริกาเกิด
เกือบทุกปีนะคะ
โอตอนแรกนะตอนแรกที่ครูหญิงถามเนี่ยอัน
นี้ก็ตลกดีครูครูนิกเนี่ยนึกถึงอันแรกคือ
อะไรรู้มยอะไร
คะใช่ถ้าเป็นภาษาไทยมันได้อยู่นะคูนิสัปร
ภาษาไทยเมันคือสับปะรสแต่ว่าคิดว่าคิดว่า
ภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะไม่ได้เรียกว่าตาน่าจะเรียก
ใช่ๆใช่แต่คนไทยจะเรียกว่าเนี่ยไงสับปะรด
มันมีตาเยอะเอออันนี้เป็นแบบปริศนาของคน
ไทยได้อ่ะตาโอเคูหญิงให้ก็ได้ 1 คะแนนนะ
คะนักเรียนตรงนี้ของสับปะรดอเนี่ยช่องอัน
เนี้ยเราเรียกว่าตาสับปะรดอื
อืมได้อ่าแต่ว่าว่ามันไม่ใช่เพราะว่ามัน
ถ้ามีที่อเมริกา
อืมันจะมีที่อเมริกาคุหญิงคิดว่ามีข่าว
บ่อย
ๆน่าจะเป็นฝั่งตะวันออกของ
อเมริกาอืเป็นลมเป็นลมเป็นลมเป็น
ลมเป็นลมด้วยอือเป็นลมพัดมาเกิดจาก
มหาสมุทรแอตแลนติก
โอ้โหพไทยไม่มีไงไทยไม่มีลมที่แรงขนาดนี้
ออ
อืแต่
ว่าโอเคครูหญิงให้ครูนิกตาต่าสับปะรดะกัน
เพราะว่ามันถือว่าเป็นคำใบ้เอ่อเป็น
ปริศนาของภาษาไทยได้เดี๋ยวุหญิงเฉลยของ
นักเรียนแล้วกันว่าอะไรที่มีตาแต่มองไม่
เห็นอืมันคืออะไรครับ
เฮอริเคนค่ะครู
นิก
อ๋อใช่เบอกว่าตรงเนี้ยมันคือตาของ
เฮอร์ริเคนน่ะอ๋อ
ออใช่แต่ว่ามองไม่เห็นมันมองไม่เห็นเออ
เออก็เป็นอันนี้ก็เป็นตอนแรกคุณนิกำลัง
คิดว่าทอร์นาโด
หรอโดแล้วทำไมมันเพราะว่ารูปมันเหมือนมัน
หมุนเหมือนตาหรอดูเก็ไม่รู้อืมใช่แต่ว่า
ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่นะคะ
อ่ะ
ก็อะไรครับ
เอิ่มอยู่ไหนอ่ะโอเคน่าจะอยู่ในนี้นะคะ
อะไร
ที่อะไรอ่ะคำถามอะไรอคำถามอะไรที่เรา
เนี่ยจะไม่ได้ตอบว่าใช่เราจะไม่มีวันตอบ
คำถามนี้ว่าใช่คือมันจะมีคำถามใช่มั้ยคะ
สมมุติว่าครูนิกกินอ่าครูนิกชอบดื่มกับ
กแฟมั้ยคุณนี้ิก็อ่ะชอบดื่มอันนี้คือใช่
แล้วก็อืไม่ชอบดื่มก็คือไม่ใช่ทุกคำถาม
เนี่ยมันจะตอบว่าใช่หรือไม่ใช่ได้แต่มัน
จะมีอยู่คำถามนึงที่เราจะไม่ตอบว่าใช่แน่
นอนหรือเราจะไม่ตอบว่า Yes ของนักเรียน
คือภาษาไทยมันสามารถใช้ได้หลายคำครับครับ
อืเราจะไม่ตอบ Yes
ชัวรเราจะตอบ Yes ไม่ได้เออไม่ใช่ไม่ตอบ
เราจะตอบว่าใช่เนี่ยไม่
ได้คำถามอะไรที่เราจะตอบคำว่าใช่ไม่
ได้คำถามอะไร
อืเป็นคำถาม
ที่คนไทยชอบถามมยก็ไม่แน่ใจนะมันอยู่ที่
คน
เอ่อถามว่านอนหรือ
ยังใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้าเกิดว่านอนแล้วก็จะ
ไม่พูดใช่
ค่ะคือตอนแรกคุณนี้ก็จะมีอีกคำถามนึงแต่
อีกคำถามนึงเนี่ยมันมันไม่ค่อยดีเท่าไหร่
ก็เลยไม่พูดดีกว่าก็เลยคิดว่านอนใช่แต่คน
ไทยอ่ะจะชอบถามแล้วพอบอกว่านอนหรือยัง
แล้วก็บอกนอน
แล้วแล้วคนไทยก็เลยจะแล้วคุณนิก็จะคิดว่า
อ้าวแล้วถ้านอนแล้วทำไมพูดได้เออนอนแล้ว
ตอบได้ยังไงใช่มเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยมันจะไม่
ได้เป็นคำถามที่แบบว่าใช่นอนแล้วก็คือใช่
นั่นเองเพราะว่าเราจะตอบว่าก็รู้ใช่ยัง
ยังไม่นอนยังไม่นอนเพราะว่าถ้าเรานอนแล้ว
เราหลับ
แล้วเราจะตอบไม่ได้นะคะมันก็เลยเป็นคำตอบ
ของข้อนี้ครูนิเก่งมากถูกแล้ว 1 อันครู
หญิงให้สับปะรดนะครูนิอ่าอ่ะเอาอีกถึงข้อ
ได้มั้ยขอข้อสุดท้ายนะคะได้ๆๆมาอ่ะอะไร
ที่มันเป็นของเรามันคือของเรานะแต่ว่าคน
อื่นเนี่ยใช้มากกว่าเราอ่ะอย่างโทรศัพท์
ใช่มั้ยโทรศัพท์เนี่ยเป็นของเราเราใช้
โทรศัพท์มากที่สุดสุดครับอืแต่ว่าอะไรที่
มันเป็นของเราแต่คนอื่นใช้มากกว่าเราเรา
ไม่ค่อย
ใช้อือันนี้มันจะออกจะ
แบบเป็นปริศนาจะกวนมั้ยก็ก็อาจจะไม่ขนาด
นั้นคล้ายๆสับปะรสใช่่มั้ยสับปะรดเนี่ยจะ
กวนตาคุณนิกกำลังคิดว่าคุณนิกกำลังคิดว่า
เราหรือเปล่าตัวเราใช่เพราะว่าก็คนอื่น
ใช้เราให้ไปทำอย่างอื่นหรือคุณเวลาเราทำ
งานก็คือมีคนมาเอาเราแล้วก็ใช้ไปทำงานอือ
แต่ว่าจะบอกว่าคิดคืออเนี้ยครูนิกตอบได้
ใกล้เคียงมากค่ะมันคืออะไรในตัวเรานี่
แหละอะไรที่มันเป็นเป็นตัวเรานี่แหละแต่
มันไม่ใช่ร่างกายของเราแค่นั้นแหละมันไม่
ใช่สิ่งที่อยู่ในร่างกายครูหญิงก็พูดบ่อย
มากอ่ะพูดูดแต่โอโอเคด้วยความที่เราใช้
แทนตัวเองมันก็อาจจะมีคำนี้ขึ้นมาเยอะอื
อะไรที่มันคือของเราอ่ะเราได้มาตั้งแต่
เกิดแต่
ว่ามีคนอื่นใช้อันเนี้ยของเราอ่ะมากกว่า
ตัวเราอีกเราไม่ค่อยได้ใช้ไม่ค่อยได้
พูด
อืทุกคนมีนะทุกคนมีใช่มมั้ยไม่ใช่ความคิด
ง่าย
ๆอะไรอ่ะ
อะไรครูนิกยอมมั้ยยอมก็คือแบบแอยอมได้
อ่ะชื่อไงชื่อของเราอ๋อเพราะคนใช้ชื่อเรา
มากกว่าเราใช่เพราะว่าปกติแล้วเนี่ยอ่า
คือถ้าเป็นฝรั่งหรือภาษาอื่นเขาจะเป็นไอ
ใช่มยเป็นไอแต่เราเนี่ยูหญิงก็จะเรียกครู
นิกคุณพ่อคุณแม่ก็นิกเพื่อนก็นิใช่มั้ย
ทุกคนจะเรียกชื่อเราเหมือนใช้ของเรามาก
กว่าตัวเราเองใช่
โอเคโอเคหรือบางหรือว่าเวลาเค้าเรียกเรา
เค้าก็เรียกชื่อมากกว่าเราเรียกชื่อตัว
เองใช่ค่ะมากกว่าเราเรียกชื่อตัวเองอื
โอเคนั่นแหละอันนี้ก็เป็นเกมปริศนานะคะ
สนุกๆครูนิเก่งมากนะแบบยังตอบได้มากเลย
ตอนเนี้ยใช่ค่ะปกติแล้วคุหญิงถึงบอกว่า
พวกเกมปริศนาเนี่ยมันต้องเป็นคนที่ชอบ
จริงๆชอบที่จะไขปริศนาเราเรียกว่าไข
ปริศนาว่าแบบอะไรมีตาแล้วมองไม่เห็นใช่
อะไรขึ้นลงแต่ขยับไม่ได้อ่าอย่างงี้เนาะ
ก็มาเล่นสนุกๆกับนักเรียนนะคะแต่ว่า
เดี๋ยวเรามาโนี้หมดเวลาแล้วเนเดี๋ยวเรามา
เจอกันใหม่วดีโอหน้าคใชครับไว้เจอกันใหม่
ครับสวัสดีครับสวัสดี
ค่ะ